so um I love this second dimension this
high low and so you use these fun
metaphors of genies and gollums where
you you had uh or originally in the you
know better version of politics you had
people arguing for their version
um in terms of facts and and policies
and then the other people on the other
side
um but then unfortunately we've gotten
now brought down a couple of levels
where it's become more tribalistic and
less reasoning
um and you characterize essentially like
the the gollum on each side as
unfortunately so certainly and I'm going
to say on the Republican side uh like
the nastier uh more
unreasoning elements of taking hold of
the party with the rise of trump
um but then you say that there is a
version on the other side too and you
referenced it a little bit when you
talked about what's going on on campuses
yeah I think um
I think that the it's not that politics
should be people being nice and agreeing
like when I think of high wrong politics
it's heated it's passionate right
there's people protesting there's
there's vigorous debate
um they might not like each other but
they're in the end they're fighting
about ideas and the underlying thing
that unites everyone up there whether
they disagree or agree is this common
goal of a better country and the it's
like a two lawyers in a courtroom their
Clash
moves the country forward right it's
like this it's like this positive sum
game
when you go to the lowrong politics
which I sometimes like to call political
Disney World because it's Disney you
know it's the land of good guys and evil
villains right and and it it's um the
mindset is not let's make a better
country together even though that's what
maybe people think it is that's not
what's going on it's let's defeat the
bad guys we're the good right we're
perfectly righteous we have no flaws and
they're evil and demonic and let's
defeat the bad guys and if only we had
it our way the country would be perfect
but there you know whatever it's this
very Us Versus Them concept
that's a zero-sum game
that moves the country backwards when
their Clash hurts the whole country
where while the clash and hyruong
politics pushes forward exactly so
they're both clashes again these are
both heated as a subtle difference
sometimes but one is arguing about ideas
and they're experimenting and and it's
not about it's not like an ethnic
tension like type thing it's not like a
um you know evil and good it's it's like
we're all here trying to do the same
thing I think you're wrong but let's
discuss it and at the bottom it is it's
this war of not ideas but it's a war of
peoples it's it's it gets into the same
kind of thing that creates religious
wars zealots versus zealots I mean they
can get very very dangerous yeah and and
by the way when you're in that
environment you feel a lot of pressure
from your own side to any kind of you
know legitimizing the other side you'll
feel it from your own side it's each
side kind of bullies themselves into
staying that way there's a lot of
Conformity pressure so how did the
Golems take control and and you write
about this at the book where like there
were different processes where you know
like that you had the right wing Golem
uh yeah right rise to power I think
Gingrich had a lot to do with it well so
so yeah the the I use the term Gollum
for like it's like the emergent property
of like low rung political group like
it's an echo chamber which a bunch of
people right who are scared to disagree
with each other
but there's an emergent thing they were
to think of this big dumb giant then I
call a Golem that like runs you know
tramps like Godzilla through Society
a liberal democracy is always going to
have Golems it's always going to have
these these kind of political tribes or
religious tribes or whatever and the the
thing that makes a liberal democracy
special isn't that it has it gets rid of
these it's that it
has an immune system to keep them from
taking over and what's happened I think
in the last
decade a few decades but especially in
the most recent decades maybe due to
social media and and a few other things
people have gotten too very very scared
of these Golems they've become scarier
you know and that has turned into the
immune the people stopping standing up
for Liberal values and going quiet
and that's the immune system failing
that's that's you know in a bit when you
scale up a bunch of scared individuals
you get a in a mass skill you get this
immune system failing and these Golems
kind of like Godzilla tramping through
Society in a way that they really
couldn't do in the older days you know
they this is this is pretty new